[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
[Music]
are you ready to vote
that is what you should be starting your
conversations with today that question
are you ready to vote
why what in the world are you talking
about Sharon well I'll tell you what I'm
talking about I'm talking about are you
ready to be Trump's jury
that's what I see this morning again I
said it yesterday we've been going over
this and over this and over this we'll
continue to go over this
he is not going to not be their nominee
there's Jack Smith will not save us
although
he will he will cause a lot of shitty
diapers in the meantime
do not count on Jack Smith saving us
this is just his his Thrice
Thrice indictment
probably not the last time he'll ever be
indicted
in state or federal court
to be quite honest
I would imagine that Georgia is coming
next I was unsure rather Jack Smith
would make the move but before
fonnie Willis the D.A in Fulton County
Georgia
it seems as if it is possible that he
will
we know that she's ready to strike maybe
that has something to do with it I you
know it's hard to tell at this point
it's hard to know history will tell the
story but we are the major part of the
story We the People
because I keep telling you this is that
if you're counting on Jack Smith in the
Department of Justice to save our
democracy
you are widely out of Step of what
actually Jack Smith's mission is
his mission is not to save the Republic
it is not
that is our job as the voters
we must focus on the ballot they are not
going to abandon him I don't know if you
noticed this this morning Rhonda Santos
didn't say [__]
Ron DeSantis is essentially the number
two he can't move in the polls the polls
right
as if we should take those seriously but
Ronda Santos's popularity is not gaining
it's losing
and he's the only one that looks like
that can challenge Trump in this primary
four delegates
the only one Nikki Haley's not gonna get
any [__] delegates neither is Tim
Scott or ASA Hutchinson
Chris Christie will be will be lucky to
even get on the debate stages
because they don't want him there
so don't don't act like don't act like
I'm not telling the truth
Rhonda santis can't even land a punch
this morning Nikki Haley tries on Fox
News she tried
major fail
whoever convinced her that she was
actually going to be a good presidential
candidate is
boy they get they got some sales skills
to be quite honest
but Ronda santis can't even throw a
punch this morning
the guy is freaking out on social media
that he is going to get indicted for
trying to overthrow our government
what more do you [__] need like Joe
Biden's not even gonna have to [__]
campaign he's just gonna be like well I
mean
look at the gay
he's got 200 felonies
yeah and it's possible it is possible
that we go into next year into the
election
and then you go into The Ballot Box and
you're voting for the guy who's
been the most effective president of our
lifetime
or the guy who has 200 felonies
dead serious and they're not turning on
him they're they're solidifying their
support with him because of this I told
you this would happen Ron I told you
months ago that this would happen and
you wouldn't [__] listen to me
no one I mean you've listened to me but
no one
oh Jesus Christ
who am I I'm just some dumb hillbilly
from Missouri who yells and screams into
the f word into the microphone
and some some think that's that's what
goes on here
hey it's just some dumb hillbilly from
Missouri that uh yells and scream the f
word into the microphone
it's a little more than that you know
that they don't know that yet
but I'm in saying it I've been telling
you over and over and over and over
again do not count on Jack Smith saving
your democracy he is not going to do it
that is not his job it is your job and
you should start your conversations
today and I'm that serious about this
you should start your conversation today
with the question are you ready to vote
even if someone hasn't heard the news
they're gonna be like what what do you
mean
am I ready to vote wow Jesus Christ
Donald Trump looks like he's saying he's
gonna get indicted for trying to
overthrow the government on January 6th
really yeah are you ready to vote are
you ready to vote
and there some of them are going to look
at you and say you goddamn right I'm
ready to vote for him I love me some
criminals
I don't get it it's a cult what you're
not supposed to really understand
exactly why it's a cult you're not
supposed to understand why really and
they haven't reached their Kool-Aid
moment yet I said that this morning on
on social media that they have not
reached their Kool-Aid moment yet I
don't know that they're going to reach
their Kool-Aid moment anytime soon
and if you're standing around hoping
that all this is is gonna make him go
away what do you think him yelling and
screaming into the [__] void this
morning on fraud social is
huh
look I understand that it's frustrating
I understand that you're pissed off that
this isn't gonna just bury him forever
and he'll go away and we'll never have
to deal with him ever again I understand
the frustration I get it I got it
but it's just not the reality it's not
it's not the reality and this morning
him sending out a [__] statement that
he got a Target letter with a bunch of
[__] fascist word salad
foreign it's not impressive to me to be
quite honest
it's not
impressive because they're not
abandoning him they're not walking away
with from him like any rational person
should that's why it's not rational it's
why it's not logical it's a cult
folks they want to believe these lies
they want the permission to be the worst
version of themselves they want the
permission to hate
and he gives them that permission more
than anyone they've ever had in their
party ever ever
he gives them that permission to hate
and to be the worst versions of
themselves and they love it
they [__] love it these vile pieces
of trash
and and you want me to lie to you okay
all right it's gonna be fine Jack Smith
totally is totally gonna indict him and
then Trump's gonna go to jail and he's
gonna be in jail cell and everything
will be great and there he won't he
won't be able to to run for president
anymore and it'll just go 14th him the
14th him before then and even though
that's not even a thing that's not a
thing I get that this morning people are
like no they're gonna 14th him with this
indictment that may be so but if they
don't try him before the election
they're not going to 14th him they maybe
eventually will for like future [__] but
not this one sorry it's not gonna happen
stop getting your hopes up stop getting
too excited about
someone else doing your job it's your
job to defend your democracy it's your
job until this country [__] comes
together and gets their [__] together
and realizes that that it's your job to
defend your democracy it's you
it's you who defends your way of life
by using the [__] ballot
that is how you do it in a democracy
until we get our heads wrapped around
that fact that simple [__] fact then
we're going to continue
to have this stupid [__] Trump
indictment roller coaster
because I'm telling you you're gonna
you're gonna be excited today you're
gonna be excited for the rest week he's
gonna get arrested and indicted it looks
like in DC you're gonna be excited
and then it's not going to be exciting
and then you're gonna have Bonnie Willis
indict him in Georgia oh it's gonna be
all kinds of excitement woohoo it's the
end yay Donald Trump's going down and
he's indebted arrested in the rain then
that's it
he's doing a town hall tonight on Fox
News
this is good for democracy
because he's not going to be able to sit
the shovel down
I mean he has the right to remain silent
he just doesn't have the [__] ability
and really honestly I wish the guy was
doing Town Halls every goddamn night
on Fox news or where whatever Trader TV
News Network that'll do it with it [__]
yeah keep talking Grandpa good talk your
way into a jail cell eventually yes do
that but I also am realistic about
federal courts and state courts and
timelines with courts I'm also realistic
about what actually happens
when you have a reasonable federal judge
who is going to set their motions folks
he's going to be winning delegates the
beginning of next year
he's going to be winning them sweeping
State delegates he is going to be a
legitimate nominee for their party which
is [__] wild and crazy it doesn't
make any sense but it's not supposed to
and the judge is going to say he's their
nominee I can't interfere in the
election we're gonna punt this thing
it's gonna happen
and if you're standing around hoping
that it doesn't you're not doing the
work you should be doing
I talked with Jess Piper yesterday you
you watched as she told you exactly what
we should be doing
yes the top of the ticket will turn turn
that turnout
into an overwhelming wash
of these [__] buffoons
we have that opportunity
but I believe we have to engage in our
democracy so much so that all the way
down to the dog catcher if they support
this fool that there is an option there
is a there is the opportunity for
someone to vote for someone who is
pro-democracy
and to not only have the opportunity but
know who they are and know who they're
going to vote for before that ballot is
cast
it's so important this is like really
important like today they're voting
you're voting in Ohio I believe Ohio's
voting today
on on
Jesus Christ
whether you're gonna have birth control
or not or other condoms are legal or not
it's [__] weird [__] man
it's a wild time to be alive it's a wild
time to be alive but you have to engage
in your democracy it is not enough just
to send a tweet saying Trump is going to
go to prison
you need to talk
to [__] around you
yes in real life you can do a lot on
social media because you can reach
around a lot of real people that there
are real people around you as well and
maybe it'll give give a sense of reality
I'm telling you you run into a trump
supporter right now
this news this morning
isn't going to make them go maybe I
shouldn't vote for him they're gonna go
you goddamn right I'm gonna vote for him
now because the idea is for him to smash
everything
the ideas for him to destroy everything
their hate has taken over
they [__] hate America they [__]
hate it
and they want to destroy it and they
want to use him to destroy it
all under the [__] guys of patriotism
and the flag
get with it
pluck your head out of your ass and
realize the doj Is Not Gonna Save Us
here this news this morning is not a
surprise to me
it's not a surprise it came earlier than
I thought I actually thought Jack Smith
would do January 6 after Georgia
I thought that that was my thought
process
I didn't think he would make a move but
maybe some of this testimony that he got
in the last few weeks from Jared Kushner
and Rudy Giuliani maybe Rudy Giuliani
flipped this morning Rudy Giuliani and
his attorneys are confirming saying you
know who knows with that [__] drunk
who knows but they're saying this
morning that Rudy Giuliani has not
received a Target letter which could
mean that the Rudy Giuliani flipped
so we'll see what comes on this
indictment
and the charges could be anywhere from
seditious conspiracy to obstructing a
proceeding
to wire fraud mail fraud who knows what
the charges could be and how many counts
that there are
and who else is wrapped up in this
indictment it's very unclear at this
point I mean we know the actors
we know the actors in in the scheme to
overthrow our election in 2020. we know
that because January 6 presented a
certain amount of evidence to the public
hell I did [__] I did hours of
streaming those those hearings for Midas
Touch you remember and really honestly
it's probably not a bad idea to start
going back and re-looking at some of
those hearings
to refresh your memory because there is
so much evidence against him and his
allies trying to overthrow our election
and it's gonna be hard to keep up
it really will
especially when Georgia makes their move
if Arizona makes a move if Michigan
Pennsylvanian Wisconsin decides to make
a move
and who knows Jack Smith could possibly
charge him in those jurisdictions as
well or others who were involved in
trying to commit a Cheeto dust kangaroo
coup
who knows
but this morning this morning even Nikki
Haley on Fox News when she was trying to
punch at him
acted like this was all Drama Oh it's
all dry it's just all drama
we don't as Republicans need the drama
we need someone who doesn't have drama
drama [__] getting a [__] in
the white house and having a stain on a
dress is drama okay
all right an intern given the president
United States a [__] in the Oval
Office is drama
that's drama man
this is not this is well beyond [__]
drama
he's charged with 37 felony counts in
the Espionage Act he's charging the
state New York with 34 counts of
business fraud he was Char his company
was charged and convicted on 17 counts
of business fraud
with seditious conspiracy
with with wire fraud mail fraud
obstructing official proceeding all on
the table available for Jack Smith the
special counsel to strike Donald Trump
with charges
by using a grand jury
come on
you're surprised get the [__] out of
here
but Nikki Haley says that's drama that's
not [__] drama
that's not drama dude
that's a coup that's treason as far as
I'm concerned he's a [__] traitor in
Marjorie Taylor green
oh boy she's tweeting this morning I
stand with President Donald Trump yeah
we know you're a [__] traitor we know
you can stop tweeting it
so ridiculous
uh she also calls Jack Smith a lousy
attorney okay
all right we'll we'll see
we'll see if Jack Smith
we'll see if Jack Smith is a better
attorney than Trump's non-attorney
attorney Tom Fenton okay we'll see who's
the better attorney Jack Smith or Tommy
Boy Old Tommy T-shirt oh Tommy where's
his sister's little shirt
I I'm telling you these people are out
of their minds they have not reached
their Kool-Aid moment yet they will get
to the Kool-Aid moment but I don't know
when but it is a cult
and this morning if you're standing
around surprised that they're not
supporting him you don't know how Cults
work
they're not going to abandon him
no matter what
you got it period period
I told Rhonda santis this [__] months
ago
months ago that Ron needed to bury him
quickly and he didn't do it well because
Ron's an idiot
and his team's an idiot apparently he
doesn't really have a team apparently
they're burning through cash like I said
they would
I told you they'd waste all that [__]
money great I mean all the political
Consultants made all kinds of cash and
they'll go work for Trump
I almost bet that's what's happening ah
man I'll get my CR hey can someone can
someone get my crystal ball out of the
closet I want to make it bring that over
here
listen here's the thing
if I get my crystal ball my guess is is
that Donald Trump the reason why Rhonda
Santos's team is leaving him is because
Donald Trump is already recruiting them
yeah 100 hundo percent too no question I
bet that's exactly what is [__]
happening
and I'm going to show you the video
we're gonna have Texas fall on he's
gonna talk I don't know if Texas Paul's
seen the news
we're gonna we're gonna talk we're gonna
talk Target letter with Texas Ball but
I'm gonna show in the the clip of Ron
DeSantis oh my God low energy Ron low
energy meatball it's not even a spicy
meatball at this point it's not it's
really Bland it tastes like [__]
pudding like you'd eat it with three
fingers or some [__]
um
but yeah Ron's Ron's flailing he's not
gonna be uh anywhere close to nominee I
would imagine
I would imagine that Ron probably comes
in third
on the Iowa straw poll hey you can hold
it to me it's Tuesday July 18th you can
mark it down Tony Michaels said at 12 23
p.m eastern time that Ron DeSantis would
come in third in the Iowa straw poll
that's right a third he'll come in third
and that'll be the end of him that'll be
the end of Ron as we know it I mean he's
already finished his political career is
already over he can't stop [__] it's
saying the word woke
as if anyone gives a [__] anymore about
the word woke besides 10 of the country
and those 10 percent that care about the
word woke are already supporting Donald
Trump they're not gonna they're not
gonna abandon him Ron you [__] idiot
and your Consultants are just robbing
all your political donations at this
point it's hilarious keep going I'm not
gonna take the shovel out of your hand I
won't
but you know that's how it goes boy we
got a hell of a show for you today of
course it's Tuesday taco Tuesday Texas
Paul is with us he's waiting in the
wings I see him there he's got his
cowboy hat Texas Paul
um I messaged him this morning I said
man it's going to be a banger of the
show and he said yeah is there news
[__] me I wouldn't [__] me I'm his
favorite turd
oh boy I want you to do something for me
a huge favor if you could right now like
this video I I failed to mention that
all the time like this video I'm a
terrible a terrible YouTuber I'm a
hairable YouTuber I'm a terrible
YouTuber
so go ahead and like the the video here
on YouTube it's like right there
somewhere you just hit the [__] rank
button and you can subscribe to YouTube
as well for free it doesn't cost a
single nickel to subscribe to the Tony
Michaels podcast so you can watch every
single episode Monday through Friday
noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific on
YouTube Twitter twitch and you can watch
it on Facebook did you know that you can
watch it live at the Tony Michaels and
if you're on Facebook you might be on
minus touches page go follow me on my
page at the Tony Michaels you're gonna
see stuff there that you won't see on
Modest that's for my show
I post memes over there I'm mean on
Facebook I don't know if you like that
and by mean I mean I go after fascist so
there's that I want to thank everyone
over on Twitch go follow us on our
follow us on Twitch it's free to follow
on Twitch I always get confused
twitch.tv slash the Tony Michaels that's
twitch.tv Tony Michaels following me on
Twitch also so many people have
re-subscribed
um just in just the last minute uh
hibbies hippies back our hibby schmack I
don't know hippies back just
re-subscribe for the fourth month in a
row don't forget if you have your Amazon
Prime account linked to your Twitch
account make sure to re-subscribe every
month to get us that that free couple
bucks that Amazon gives us when you tie
and link your Amazon Prime account and
your Twitch account and give us that one
free subscription you get with Amazon
gaming if you haven't done it already
just go to the Tony michaels.com that's
the Tony michaels.com the directions are
there they're really simple are great
are moderator the mighty librarian put
these directions together for you to
link the two your Amazon and your Prime
account or your Prime account and your
Twitch account excuse me it's right
there on the Tony michaels.com it's the
fourth link down you just click it also
on that same link there's directions on
how to resubscribe takes like three
seconds
it takes longer to read the direction
than to actually do it so go to the Tony
michaels.com link your Amazon Prime
account to your Twitch account get
commercial free viewing on Twitch and we
get a couple bucks it's kind of cool
doesn't cost you a single nickel to give
us some money kind of cool also if you
want to visit the merch store we have
some merch going on over there we still
have [__] them fanny packs so go to
store not d20michaels.com we appreciate
all the support over there and download
every single episode in the afternoon on
Apple's Spotify and giggle
it's very important that you download
the episode the audio version
because it gets us in the rankings the
more you download it the more ratings
you give us over there
on these directories whether it be apple
Spotify Google we get we get ranked
so more people see and listen to the
show that's the important part so go
ahead and download every single episode
every single weekday ah man
I got a lot of Clips to show you we got
a lot of news to get through
I'm still debating whether I'm gonna
read Grandpa's entire word salad
of his whining and crying about being
indicted again for crimes that he
committed I don't know I don't know if
we'll read the whole [__] thing maybe
we'll read a bit of it don't go anywhere
we'll be right back it's Tuesday it's
tacos and it's Texas Paul stick around
we'll be right back right after this
what the [__] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment we're
back to the Tony Michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome back to the show
Target letter Tuesday
got this letter on Sunday
and it took it took till this morning
to get his lawyers his lawyers to
convince to probably not say anything
he's supposed to have a town hall on Fox
News tonight I can't wait for those
clips tomorrow oh my God
you know that some [__] is gonna bring
his shovel to that town hall
you damn right he'll bring a shovel I
think Texas Paul wants him to bring a
backhoe a backhoe to the town hall
tonight what do you say Texas Paul good
morning my friend
yet you're muted there you're muted
there sir
it worked the microphone works a hell of
a lot better and you're still yeah I
still can't hear you I don't know what's
going on nope can't hear you
'll figure he'll figure it out I'll talk
over him while he's uh while he's
working there I know what Texas Paul is
thinking he's thinking Target letter
what Target letter I didn't read Twitter
this morning are you kidding me no I
still can't hear you still don't have
you and he's gonna go out and come back
in
I don't know what happened sometimes we
have technical difficulties here on the
show what are you gonna do it's
technology it's technology that's how it
goes
um I also I also am going to show Texas
Paul the um the video of uh Kevin
McCarthy again I again I would love to
say that Trump's not going to be their
nominee but when the Speaker of the
House of Representatives
who who chastise Trump for trying to
overturn the government who chastised
Trump to call for his supporters to go
violently to the Capitol to try to hang
Mike Pence chastised him on the floor of
the house and now he's a speaker of that
same chamber and this morning he's like
oh this is all an attempt to rig an
election and I'm sure that he didn't
hear any of that from Donald Trump this
morning right okay yeah right
um okay
that may be yeah okay now Kevin McCarthy
totally was given Direction by
by Donald Trump this morning to what to
say and when to say it and it was like
oh well it's really it's really
something that they would indict him on
something that he did uh uh four years
ago
but because Hunter Biden laptop and
cocaine crack slide I don't know
no I'm serious they they posted uh
pictures of Hunter Biden on a water
slide
doing and crack cocaine and with
prostitutes I don't know some around
California on a water slide looks like
fun they I tell you what they just make
me like Hunter Biden more every single
[__] day honestly they're like this
guy knows how to party like okay so
what's the problem what's the problem
again he knows how to party I I don't
understand this
Texas Paul let's see if we got him now
how's it my friend oh there it is there
it is that's it that's it he's woke as
[__] this morning look at his his mug
there
I tell you yeah it's the last last
couple days has been the most
technological disastrous [__] I've ever
dealt with oh yeah everything you know I
mean I got to take everything off auto
update man my my wave XLR system updated
and um
it was crazy
that that microphone those two okay so
this I use a wave link uh and this is
the wave this is the wave microphone
Elgato for anyone who knows anything
about microphones and Equipment that's
what I use I don't know I've seen you I
seen you're on Howl show yesterday I
watched a bit of it you guys were
talking about Russia and Ukraine is that
part of your technical difficulty
switching back and forth to that
now man it's just everything's doing
Auto freaking updates and uh when my
when my wavelength software updated it
turned my headphones all the way up and
I was getting a monitoring loop
everything I'd say I was getting a
monitoring light is there it was there
an update the last couple days because I
mean that mine's gonna do it too
that's half my problem when I have it
this morning stream yard decides that my
microphone that I've been using forever
is not my default microphone that is not
your default microphone Texas fault not
anymore and they have decided they want
a different one for you and it happens
to be every once in a while too I gotta
restart my [__] I think it was yesterday
or day before I got to restart my entire
thing to get it to to get it to wake the
[__] up and speaking of waking up I
texted you this morning said hey this
show is going to be a banger and you you
didn't seem to know the news have you
been on Twitter since
yeah
no I I knew he'd been to Ohio
I you know well I I I've pretty well
figured that
um but I thought it was worth mentioning
because it was funny and yeah I walked
out in the yard and walked by there was
a line of ants man we're walking down
the sidewalk and then looked down one of
them said hey major your truck was
indicted
everybody
I said hey did you did you hear Trump
got a Target letter oh that's hilarious
well you know about that because Sunday
apparently Sunday he received this
this target letter which he seems it's
significant that he received it on
Sunday like it all it tells me is that
Jack Smith is working seven days a week
man like that should terrify you not you
shouldn't be confused like what are they
doing sending me a letter on Sunday like
that should scare the [__] out of you
that they're working seven days a week
that they'll send you a goddamn Target
letter on a Sunday number one but I
think it is significant that he didn't
immediately tell us about it yesterday
um so it sounds it sounds like uh the
lawyers that he does have near him are
trying to take this seriously
um and and and but I don't think that
cooler heads are going to Prevail
because he's released this statement
this morning before his town hall on Fox
News which I'm sure again he's gonna
bring the biggest [__] shovel for his
political grave that he can bring and
say all kinds of crazy [__] because
we're talking about January 6 now this
is not about the documents case we have
moved we have moved pass the indictment
on the documents case uh to pretty much
him looking guilty into now to the
January 6th to see what that indictment
is going to say and is it going to be as
detailed because that's what I want to
that's what I want to see here if we get
an indictment what are the charges and I
want to see if Jack Smith writes this
indictment like he wrote the indictment
in the documents case
yeah I mean and and I think the part
that everybody's glossing over is this
just wasn't a Target letter it was it
was an order to appear I mean he's he's
got to come testify I mean he's going to
sit there and plead the fifth 37 000
times you know but but you know the fact
that you think you'll go do you think
he'll go he ain't gonna go he has to
yeah no no no no no no no no no target
letter is not good no I don't I don't
think he's gonna go and I don't think I
think he's got a choice because you got
your Fifth Amendment right not to
self-incriminate yourself even if you
have to sit there and you have to yeah
search your fifth amendment rights you
can't not appear when your summons to
appear before a grand jury that's not
it's it's it's it I think it's an
invitation I think it's an imitation in
this target letter I haven't seen the
target letter and maybe we'll find out
um but I I don't think he goes even even
if there's a chance of him being
arrested I don't think he would go
because if he goes and says anything
he's [__] he knows that that's why
he's never really wanted to get in front
of a grand jury no matter if it was
civil or criminal in the first place is
because he knows the truth he knows the
truth and and we'll see the one Glimpse
that we have into what the indictment
may look like though because some people
are saying there's like a draft draft
indictment out there but that's based on
no evidence that they've seen only
public evidence the evidence uh judge
Carter a federal judge judge Carter at
California who got rid of the attorney
client privilege with John Eastman's
emails
um judge Carter said the reason why
there's no attorney-client privilege in
those emails between Trump and Eastman
is because he believed that they
committed the crime and conspiracy to
commit the crime of obstructing of a
official proceeding that seems to be one
of the easiest charges to guess here
don't you think the obstruction of a
official proceeding just because of what
we've seen from Judge Carter
well absolutely I mean they
it's been
Jack Smith just modus operandi the whole
time is he's taking he's taking Trump
and he's just staking him to the ground
with the easiest most clear-cut and most
easy to understand easiest to prosecute
charges and then he'll come back with
superseding indictments later for the
more complicated stuff uh you know if
Trump doesn't you know try to profit or
I mean if if they don't
Trump I'm with Chris Christie on this
I'll be honest with you I am with Chris
Christie on this I mean Jack Smith is
laying out
charges that Trump's lawyers are telling
him
we're gonna lose I mean we're just gonna
lose you need to prepare yourself for
the fact that we're going to lose and
I think as I honestly believe this as it
becomes more apparent that running for
president isn't going to save his butt
he's gonna fly I mean he's not in the
flip a pardon me he's gonna he's gonna
take a deal he is he's going he's going
to take it you think Trump's going to
take a deal
yeah eventually
as it sinks in
he's not gonna flip on anybody he's
going to save the the country the the
you know
you think Trump is gonna it's gonna go
easy on us
I don't know I totally disagree that I
don't think he's gonna take a damn deal
it's the only it's the only card he's
sitting on left Tony I mean it's the
only thing he has left is to save us the
trouble of Prosecuting him and if he
pleads out to
some reduced charges
minimal jail time it's the best thing
for him I mean eventually I agree with
Chris Christie on that I don't agree
with Chris Christie on [__] but I agree
with him on this
you know it's one thing to sit there and
have bravado and think that you're gonna
you know beat this you're going to run
for office and you're gonna pardon
yourself in this but when the reality of
it comes in that he's trailing Biden in
the polls that he's
not going to get reelected he's not
going to save himself he's really going
to have to deal with the Fallout from
this that old man is gonna have some
real quiet time in his bedroom by
himself sitting on the edge of the bed
thinking
I mean I'm not really sure how they
incarcerate a former prison I'm really
that's one thing on that I don't I I
have no good prediction on like how they
incarcerate a former president
I have no idea I don't know what a
federal judge and the Bureau of Prisons
decide if he's convicted of some of
these felonies but there's so many
[__] felonies there's so many [__]
felonies that he's gonna catch one that
is the entire [__] point of what the
prosecutors are doing right whether it's
whether it's uh the Manhattan D.A
whether it's Jack Smith in in the
District of Washington DC or the
southern Florida District right or it's
Bonnie Willis in Fulton County The
Fulton County D.A it doesn't matter the
idea is to pile as many [__] charges
on top of someone that you possibly can
charge possibly pile on them with the
grand jury with the evidence that you
have so you can land one punch like
that's the idea is to land a punch now
they want to get all of them obviously I
know I don't think they're going to get
him on every single charge right and
very rarely does that actually happen
when there's this many charges
but I think that's the idea I guess
maybe the bet is is how many felonies
will he be charged with by the time we
get to the election next year I think
it's going to be over 200. I think
that's incredible that he's going to
have over 200 felonies whether it's
convicted or charged and I'm including
the 17 on the Trump organization because
I think those count everyone's like oh
that's his business yeah but it's him
what the [__] you want it's him it's him
so I I think go ahead go ahead I'll tell
you what's blowing my mind on this Tony
is so far all of the prosecutors Alvin
Bragg everybody have been they've been
pretty much well
Marching In lockstep you know don't piss
on each other's cases don't you know
what I mean but you've got funny well
she's coming out next month and she's
going to indict she's going to indict
she's already said she's she's going to
announce her indictment decisions next
month but she's called for a ton of
security at at the courthouse and
yeah she's going to indict
that's really running into the same
timeline that Jack Smith is putting
forward here because I I don't know if
you know this but if you're the target
of an investigation you're the last
person they talk to right well and there
may be there may be some sharing up with
some evidence after but they have their
case built before they come talk to you
they know the answer to every damn
question that they're going to ask you
and they just sit you down in a room
hand you a bunch of rope and say hang
yourself well and that's why that's why
I say this target letter it I believe
and maybe I'm wrong but I believe it's
not a subpoena it is not an order it is
an invitation for him to come hang
himself in front of a grand jury my my
my actual understanding is is that a
target of Investigation does not have to
appear in front of the grand jury that's
the whole point of a Target letter is
hey you're the Target and we're going to
try to indict you you had the
opportunity to come tell our story but
you don't have to because you you're the
target it is your it is your right as
someone who is a target or someone who's
about to be indicted not to not to give
any kind of information anything you're
it's your burden of proof that I
committed a crime and you can present it
to the Grand Jury but I'm I'm not I'm
not obligated to give you anything until
you indict me once they indict you
that's a different story now you're in a
different situation that's my
understanding and and maybe maybe I'm
wrong I don't think I am but maybe I am
but here's the thing I don't think
Donald Trump
goes before any grand jury
unless he's forced to which he won't be
forced to I don't think Donald Trump
takes a deal and I don't think Donald
Trump realizes the Jeopardy that he's in
until probably the summer of 2025. that
would be my guess is when he knows he's
in really big trouble that he can't
delay anymore this is not going to stop
it's not going to Halt he won't be
president he'll be whining and
complaining that I lost the dead 2020
election was rigged in the 2024 election
this week he's going to try the same old
[__] honestly I hope he tries the same
stupid [__] especially if they charge
him for the wire fraud for defrauding
his supporters for the legal funds that
he didn't use for the legal funds when
he knew that he lost because that's
really at the heart of this that's what
Jack Smith has to prove here to put
Donald Trump away for a long time no
matter when the trial is I believe it'll
be after the election but he has to
prove that Donald Trump knew
that
that he had lost the 2020 election
that he knew he lost now where that
evidence comes from and if it comes
directly from him I don't know maybe
they do have the evidence maybe they
have the test test the testimony from
Rudy Giuliani Jared Kushner and others
what do you think do you think Rudy's
flipped apparently he hasn't received a
uh a Target letter let me show you the
news on that what do you think do you
think Rudy's flipped
Rudy flipped Mark Meadows flipped
Cassidy Hutchinson is actually one of
the things that really just talk about
building The Gallows and handing them
rope man her testimony that uh uh you
know she's both publicly and privately
has said that there was a conversation
between her and Trump I mean pardon me
between Trump and Mark Meadows that she
was privy to that
Trump told Meadows I don't want people
to know I lost
right I don't want people to know I lost
here is Paula Reed with CNN that makes
everything he did after that fraud
right he's but yeah Rudy flipped he
spent two days with Jack Smith and uh
his lawyers confirmed yeah his lawyers
confirmed this morning that he has not
received a Target letter yeah this is
from Paula Reed and she's confirmed this
Marie Giuliani has not received a Target
letter in the 1-6 probe meaning the Jack
Smith investigation his lawyers tell me
as CNN previously reported really did
voluntary the interview with the special
counsel's investigators several weeks
back his lawyer does not expect him to
be charged which um if you had extended
conversations with the special counsel
and you don't expect to be charged it's
possible that you've already made your
deal now in in in a lot of criminal
cases federal criminal cases even
someone who quote flips or gives
um gives their testimony against a
certain Target still sometimes receives
charges that is possible but it doesn't
seem that that's what Rudy's attorneys
are saying at this moment oh he's taking
charges I guarantee you man I I
guarantee I think in Georgia he's gonna
get I think in Georgia he's going to get
charged if not Arizona as well dreary
Giuliani and that that's for damn sure
um let me go to uh the Fox news this
morning with Nikki Haley I'm going to
show you Nikki Haley she's oh she's
she's got like I don't know a half a
percent of her support in the Republican
party right now for being president so
you know let's let's ask her and see
what she thinks surely she'll throw a
punch here uh should I ask you a
question first okay yeah go ahead
nimrata was a governor I get it she was
she was a she was a governor okay
and but she's nobody in the Republican
party anymore nobody I mean she why do
we constantly have to look and hear from
these people that have nothing
consequential to say I mean nothing
whatsoever consequential to add to the
conversation you know you're about to
show this clip that's just
I mean it's like a slap in the face oh
it's just drama anyways I'm sorry man
why the hell are we Florida
well I'll tell you why I'll tell you why
it's because Republicans still want to
pretend like their party isn't a cult
they want to pretend that way but it's
not it's a [__] cult that's what it
is she was part of the cult
and and she perpetuates it here with
this her answer here listen remarkable
uh there was more breaking news I'm
going to get your um reaction to this
within the past 30 minutes former
president Donald Trump announced that he
uh has been notified as of Sunday night
that he says he is the target of an
indictment as it relates to January 6.
your reaction to that and how does that
affect the race because you have
qualified for the first debate how does
this indictment affect his candidacy
it's going to keep on going I mean the
rest of this primary election is going
to be in reference to Trump is going to
be about lawsuits it's going to be about
legal fees it's going to be about Judges
and it's just going to continue to be a
further and further
um distraction and that's why I am
running is because we need a new
generational leader we can't keep
dealing with this drama we can't keep
dealing with the negativity we can't
it's crime Nikki it's crime okay it's
crime you [__] idiot it's not drama
it's crime and they're Prosecuting it
that's
that's what it is it's [__] wild [__]
it's wild [__] that that she's divining
in is drama it's not surprising though
from her because she doesn't want to
punch too hard because I think Nikki
Haley is still hoping that maybe Donald
Trump will pick her as her Vice his vice
presidential running man what do you
think you think that's you think yeah
do you think do you think her and her
team are still talking about that though
they're like oh yeah we still got a
chance no no yeah I you know I have no
idea I have no you know going back to
Chris Christie for a second in regards
to her Chris Christie's not running out
of money
Chris Christie has big GOP backers
behind him and you know he doesn't think
he's going to be now Chris Christie
cannot have any delusion whatsoever that
he's going to be the actual nominee
yeah he's in there to swing to to
kneecap Trump and to try to save the
party that's what he's there for I I
think the other thing is 20. I think
he's there for 2028 too if you want to
know the truth I think I think I think
Christy's trying to stay relevant until
2028 this is one of the attempts but go
ahead go ahead
but I mean compare that to what nimrata
here I mean who what is her gain
I mean she's got two choices she can
either do a Chris Christie who's
obviously being well financed to go on
this mission to piss off half the
Republican base to try to save its soul
and
I kind of just vomited in my mouth a
little bit
but yes he's trying to save his party
Soul that's what he's doing what is
nimrodden here doing I mean what is she
doing
I think originally she thought she this
would make her a Vice Presidential
nominee
put her on the ticket with Trump and
deliver her some sort of relevancy into
2028. I don't know she's ridic she's
horrible at it if she whatever she's
doing she's horrible at it well yeah
because I mean the entire clip did you
not just sit there and scream yeah Trump
needs to
you know take the take take a deal and
get off the stage I mean that was the
message I heard not not not what she was
trying to say that everybody needs to
quit picking on Trump and all that you
know what I mean but the message I heard
was that you know and ASA Hutchinson is
out doing that today have you have you
heard him he no well he got he got booed
and they were chanting Trump at the uh
turning points Nazi rally over the
weekend yeah
um he just he just told Trump flat out
so he needs to step down yeah well I
mean who gives a [__] what ASA
Hutchinson says I mean I don't give a
[__] what he says the Republicans
definitely don't so ASA Hutchinson
calling for Donald Trump to drop out of
the race is gonna go over like a wet
fart in a white thong it's just not
gonna work very well speaking of wet
farts and white thongs uh here's the
epitome of one Kevin McCarthy he's the
speaker of the house did you know that
this guy this guy is the de facto kind
of sort of speed they let him have the
office of the speaker of the house and
did you know also Texas Paul that after
the Insurrection after the violent
Insurrection on January 6 when Grandpa
poopy pants when the Cheeto dust q and
honor called for his his supporters to
go down to the Capitol and stop them to
certify the election they called The
Hang Mike Pence they cried they tried
their damnedest to have a coup and to
make Donald Trump the king of the United
States of America Kevin McCarthy before
he was speaker he went on the floor of
the house and chastised Trump chastised
him for that but now now that he's being
charged in that case of January six
let's see what the speaker of the house
has to say I'm sure it's not treasonous
at all well I guess us under a Biden
Administration by America you'd expect
this if you notice recently president
Trump went up in the polls and was
actually surpassing President Biden for
re-election
weaponize government to go after their
number one opponent
it's time and time again I think the
American public is tired of this
they want to have see Equal justice and
the idea that they utilize this to go
after those who politically disagree
with him is wrong but I keep telling you
there's plenty of evidence out there
this only adds to the mountain of
evidence that they're going to nominate
Trump it's right there the speaker of
the house he is the highest office
holder of any Republican in this entire
country and he is genuine reflecting to
Trump he is all but deep throating him
on national TV going it's all Biden's
fault that Trump committed crime and now
he's being charged with it get the [__]
out of here man get the hell out of here
if they attack Trump they're telling
their voters they were wrong and they
cannot do that they just cannot do that
but I tell you what when you queued that
up yeah actually you remember that old
Johnny Carson comedy bit where he put
the big turbine on and he was yeah hold
the document up right and he'd know what
I mean yeah no yeah that's exactly what
I was feeling when when you queued that
up I'm like I could tell you what he's
going to say right everybody could tell
you what's good right right right well
and the reason why you know exactly what
he's gonna say you just need to go watch
Trump's rallies and he's gonna say the
[__] that Trump has told him to say
because Kevin McCarthy is only speaker
let me let me tell the American people
this Kevin McCarthy is only speaker of
the house because Donald Trump keeps him
the speaker of the house I don't know if
you know that or not but that is the
best reason man I know
they're just nailed it Karnak I couldn't
remember his name for anything and she
said like immediately car neck the
Magnificent
here's Cynthia you know I used to uh
I've watched John I you might not think
I'm old enough but I've watched Johnny
Carson I watched Johnny Carson then Jay
Leno of course on The Tonight Show but
you know who's I I couldn't come up with
that um that character but it is a good
one it was a good one of Carson's oh my
God no but you know Tony what you were
saying there man I mean it's so freaking
spot on I mean and and it's like
watching uh like some crime drama
you know where where you see you know
Patty Hearst or somebody like that that
they can't they can't go against the
cult man they cannot they can't because
if they do and and these are not the
people in The Cult we're talking about
the people that work with the cult
leader
um do you remember that that crazy uh I
can't remember her name uh
starts with a J but she used to morph
into this character ramtha where she
would sit there and say you know she
would like do this spiritual thing and
then she would be this 2 000 year old
Guru and she had this whole cult
following yeah uh and then then are you
serious like it's a real thing this
isn't a [__] it's a real thing she had
a big-ass horse farm around here
um they uh no really no [__] they yeah
and she would like switch
without doing the whole uh
praying thing and the people around her
were like yeah we knew we knew when they
finally broke it up they're like we knew
you know there were too many times she
just went from we should really get some
more sandwiches for this and the other
God is telling me to tell you to you
know I mean it was just it was that's
exactly what we're seeing with these
Republicans man that's exactly
Judy denuda is that someone's no no no
no no no I can't remember her name Jay I
want to say Jay-Z something or other or
something like that but anyways she's
not important what's important is that
these Republicans are doing the exact
same thing all of them Kevin McCarthy
knows I mean he freaking knows man but
he cannot piss off the cult
he cannot piss off the call he cannot
tell them
you're wrong about Donald Trump you're
just wrong your daddy that told you you
could be as awful as you wanted to be
and then on the other end of it it's
like the other side of that sword is
just slicing them apart because you see
what's happening with DeSantis
everybody's looking at this hand to say
you're a dick
oh he's horrible you're a dick you know
and like we don't want 40 Years of
looking at you and listening to you
you're a dick you know right and and
that they'd have no clue what to do
I want to get to this question she says
do other cultures love Cults as much as
Americans yes they absolutely do cult uh
cult is Almost Human Nature to be quite
honest that's why that's why I keep
saying you're not you don't need to get
too excited about whether he's gonna be
their nominee or not he's going to be
because it is a cult and you're you're
if you don't understand now Colts work
you're not understanding why he's going
to be
um but it's not just an American thing
uh there's the reason why in America it
seems like we have
well such an affixiation with Cults is
because
um we we do we do have uh quite the
freedom and liberty here uh of freedom
of speech and that that allows a lot of
these cult leaders to uh manipulate and
delude their supporters and their
supporters to then dilute other people
and bring them into the cult I mean it's
a whole operation as far as how the uh
how The psychosis works but no it's not
just an American thing but speaking of
cultists oh my god did you see Marjorie
Taylor hoof foot green this morning with
her statement oh man you gotta watch
this you know she's she's [__] pissed
and I couldn't be happier to be going on
yeah this this is man it's like you're
right on exactly what I was thinking
when I was when I saw Kevin McCarthy I
wanted to ask you this who's his caucus
who's his faction in in it you know what
I mean it's like him and Marge and who
the hell else man right
but here's how's the speaker I don't I I
well Trump trump allowed him to be
speaker and he genuflected to Trump and
he continues to Jenny Fleck to Trump and
Trump keeps in speaker the minute that
Trump does not want Kevin McCarthy's
speaker he will not be speaker anymore
you can damn well better bet that
Nancy Pelosi had an entire faction of
people that if you came out against
Nancy were ready to punch you right in
the freaking mouth
that's what it takes to be speaker you
know Johnson used to literally walk
people to the back of the chamber and
twist literally twist their arms behind
their back push them against the back of
the chamber and whisper in their ear
you're gonna vote for what I said
I did that I mean really literally that
Michael beschlas talked about that a lot
I mean he was a real they say he was
Hands-On they mean he was hands on LBJ
was a zombie huge man he was a yeah he
was a big [__] and he was from
Texas so he thought he might he thought
he was tough and he probably was tough
too have you ever I asked Gabe Sanchez
this yesterday have you ever heard the
uh the the message or the phone call
that's recorded of of LBJ ordering pants
have you ever heard that no oh my God
it's [__] hilarious we'll watch that
today we'll watch that day I want to
laugh at you on that but let's laugh at
Marge here because she's super pissed
off and again she's mad as hell that
Trump's gonna be indicted and I couldn't
be happier that she's mad as hell let's
watch uh president Trump says he
received a letter from Jack Smith saying
to Target of a grand jury investigation
of January 6th you have a reaction to
that yeah it's absolute [__] yeah
that's my
um this is the only way that the
Democrats have to beat president Trump
is to arrest him smear him charge him
with ridiculous charges all in a
cover-up of Joe Biden's crimes Hunter
Biden's crimes okay Texas Paul she lets
the cat out of the bag here so she
projects that the only way that they can
beat Donald Trump is to arrest him and
charge him with crimes all the while all
they're doing every day is we need to
lock Joe Biden up because he met there
there's this guy who's a Chinese spy who
said who said he's a criminal and we
believe him because we want to believe
him like literally their entire strategy
is to charge Hunter Biden and Joe Biden
with crimes and lock them up so Joe
Biden can't be president and she's
telling you out loud with projection
she's like that's the only way that they
can win and she's telling you that's the
only way they are going to win is by
charging
Joe Biden with crimes and locking him up
we see that we we see that everywhere
but that's what she's saying here I
think
you know I wonder if she's actually
stupid enough to believe the [__] she
says though man I mean like you saw the
video the other day when she was she was
offering the amendments to the to the
ndaa the defensive bill right
um she actually said that we're sending
f-16s to Ukraine I that's used to me we
are not sending f-16s to Ukraine I mean
and and I just want she's just stupid
enough to she just thinks if she said
stuff I mean I don't even think she
thinks that far into it I think she's
just dumb enough that she actually
thinks that kind of stuff and I wonder
here
sometimes and I I'm I'm not latching on
to this as a theory yet but it just
sometimes I listen to her and I'm like
she really believes that anything you do
politically is like fair game that it's
that it's not a crime there isn't a line
there you know she thinks that that
Congressional immunity the the speech
and debate clause covers treason and and
and and I just I sometimes really
believe that she's just that stupid that
she really doesn't understand that when
you took part in that meeting on the
fifth you know and and you know you did
all the you were in the room doing the
planning
that [__] you asked for a pardon for
right
I mean maybe that's what she's scared of
I don't know let's listen to the rest of
her little
uh vomiting here
it's hard to even recognize that this is
our country
um the American people are going to be
furious and and what Jack Smith is doing
is is the weaponized government and he's
weaponizing the Department of Justice
against President Trump in a complete
lie about President Trump and January 6.
okay so she says the American people are
going to be furious Texas Paul the
American people don't know [__] about
this this morning they really don't us
who pay attention to politics
we know what's going on most people out
there in the world who are just doing
their jobs going to work getting coffee
stopping and dropping their kids off at
daycare so they can get to work on time
they're in traffic maybe they had to
change a tire because they got a flat
they don't give a [__] about what Donald
Trump said this morning that is the
thing that people just don't get about
the politics of our country they're not
going to give a [__] about any of this
until sometime next summer that is it
they're not they don't know that Trump
got a Target letter they have no clue
they're not watching the news they're
not trust me on this most Americans have
no clue that Donald Trump received
another [__] Target letter now when
he is indicted the
America will know that he got arrested
again that's literally the two words two
words that America will know that day
arrested again Trump arrested again
those two words that's it that's all
they're gonna know that's all they need
to know they're going to hold that
information until next summer this idea
that America knows every single detail
of this case they know exactly what
happened on January 6th they know the
estate elector scheme they know he stole
documents it's possibly stole documents
to cover up the January 6th that's why
Jack Smith is now indicting him based on
that who knows but they don't know that
[__] stop acting like America's
Americans give a [__] about any of this
stuff we do we do as commentators you do
as an audience because you want to
engage in your politics and that's why
it's so important that you do engage and
you do get involved is to let these
people make these people understand that
this is important [__] to know because
they don't know it they don't know he's
received the target letter this morning
could care less too she her saying the
American people are angry as dumb as dog
[__] they're not mad you know speaking
of dumbest dog [__] I mean you've got a
perfect example in your audience right
now you've got a troll in there by the
name of Astro who just said right yeah
they said January 6 was was Nancy Pelosi
setup now I I've got to you know look at
that logic a little bit it's a January
it's a Nancy Pelosi setup which means
something happened
something happened but on the other end
it was just a peaceful protest and it
was just tourists and it was just nobody
did anything wrong and then he goes on
to make the argument to show you how
freaking stupid your average Maga person
is the next thing he comes out is just
well it was an Insurrection with
flagpoles
Astro here I think Astro is is making
jokes in the uh maybe maybe not they
might be a troll but I think I think
Astro rather there rather they're
actually a troll or not they're saying
the stuff that trolls would say right so
and that's that's the idea is that is
that it's saving me for myself
I know stop it stop it
[Laughter]
some people are saying some people now
this this troll is on Twitch
um which uh they're saying oh no he's a
troll uh if if that if the moderator's
over there on Twitch I'll leave the
troll in there for a little bit for me
why not we'll have some fun with him if
it's really a troll but the thing is is
that he's a beautiful example Tony
exactly beautiful example of just how
moronic they are I mean if he's really a
troll think about how smooth his brain
has to be to say on one hand oh this was
a setup a setup for what a setup to do
what how were you set up what is it that
you were set up to do a crime a crime
did you you were set up to commit a
crime is that what we're talking about
and then on the other hand it's oh it
was nothing man it was just an
interaction with flagpoles nothing
happened well what is it man is it a
setup or nothing happened because if it
was a setup obviously some [__] happened
and you're you know those people got in
trouble for doing something wrong I mean
if it's really a freaking setup I mean
we are we already blocked the trolls and
you know but we can guess
we can we can guess what they're gonna
say just like we can probably guess what
Gabe Sanchez is gonna say I I almost I
can almost guess what he's gonna say
what do you think Gabe Sanchez
I am the troll oh oh I see what it is
you are the troll well that makes sense
that makes sense that makes sense
he's been back there telling his partner
watch how red I can make Texas Paul
watch it
watch I did it he did it
yes Gabe Gabe is here and Gabe is the
troll I am I am a uh I am your mic is
hot today is it loud it feels like it's
hot let's see hang on no yeah we got it
on automatic yeah yeah
okay that's good that's good now that's
better I think it finally Auto adjusted
um yeah yeah it was me it was me still
trolling right that's right that's right
that's right so what do you make of the
um the target this morning which one
Margaret Taylor green Donald Trump
I mean anyone who asked for a pardon or
had meetings in December leading up to
January 6th you got to ask the question
what are they doing right now and how
full of their diapers okay because I
asked to pull this morning I said how
full do you think Donald Trump's diaper
is moderately full very full holy [__]
it's overflowing what what was the
result that have you got anymore I
haven't I haven't looked at it right now
oh okay this is on your Twitter Ralph
Walt not a sleeve right now man
you think you think oh Walt teen is
changing them Pampers you think oh he's
the new wet wipes I mean you push you
push that red button he gets a Diet Coke
and a new new pair of diapers you know
fresh a fresh fresh pear fresh pamper oh
Jesus Christ okay let's see I'm trying
to find this pole on your uh there it is
okay I'm gonna see if we can um I'll
bring it up here I'll vote live here how
full is Trump's diaper holy [__] it's
over
wow all right wow I think I think I
think we can call it off right now
there's still 24 hours left but I think
you can I think we call that
[__] off right now wow that's
that's that's great I was not I had not
after I pushed send and I I was on a
work call and I was doing some stuff and
so like I just didn't I you know I
haven't looked at it what I want to know
is who are these [__] the
someone very very full maybe those are
people who are like uh it's all coming
it's all coming for Trump but maybe
those people are like he hasn't like
accepted reality yet so he's like still
in denial maybe that's what those people
are saying maybe the blue checks that
follow you too over on Twitter oh that
could be the blue checks you know what
do you think exactly who those people
are you know exactly those are those
people that come into your your Twitter
feed and your and you tell them you tell
them exactly oh erdogan has turned on
Russia and here's why this happened this
happened this happened and then they're
the guy that pops into your uh Twitter
feed and said but you don't know so this
is what's really happening yeah this is
what's really going on everybody hates
that guy I mean they just you mean they
just puke up Russian propaganda is that
the one okay well you posted uh no it's
worse Tony it's the ones that are on
your side that are like ow oh you mean
you follow this 24 7 for a living well
let me tell you what my account at NAS
thinks about what's going on in the real
world that you don't know I mean I hate
that guy I do I love my audience but
that freaking guy I have I have lingered
over the block button so many freaking
times
oh boy well you're you had something to
say about Marge's little post here this
morning you said the margin Taylor green
is like a kid who learned the phrase
little [__] and can't stop saying it
it's true she had she tweeted it this
morning on her official account yeah I
know she's this is the creator this is
how you know that these people are
getting very scared I mean even the
video or the the uh hallway interviews
that they got with Margie Taylor green
this morning we just showed it yeah
yeah asking asking about what her you
know what her opinion was and the fact
that she's not being Coy with her
language the fact that she's using her
actual representative account to say
things like oh Jack Smith is a is the
Democrats weak little [__] shows you
how afraid these people are because
again remember there were people that
were revealed Margaret Taylor green Matt
Gates and several several others who
were tested a pardon now you don't ask
for a pardon if you were innocent you've
committed a crime you've done something
wrong you're admitting Fault by just
even saying well I'm just I'm just see
I'm just putting some feelers out what
what can what can I is it a possibility
like let's say that I did do something
is it a possibility that it could get a
pardon like the fact that anyone's
having that conversation or that thought
or even like a you know a [__] water
cooler whisper talk
reveals
that there is something wrong that they
did wait do they do they gather around
the water cooler or the pipe bomb I
don't know well they they gather around
the water cooler they all say okay
Marcus
oh okay okay you know that's the thing
that happens you know
I see I see yeah I see well you know the
funny part about this I've got a party
gag for that whenever I'm at one of
these caucuses or something or you're
having an actual Gathering you know and
everybody will be sitting around we'll
you know I'll bring up Marjorie Trader
green and then I'll bring up the pardons
that and the other and then let them
stew on it for a second and say and I
asked him and I'll ask you guys what
would you ask for a pardon for
oh there it is there is there it is look
at those looks on their faces they went
back and they Shackled through their
mind and they found that right I got a
lot of [__] out here I got a lot of [__]
on that dance for a pardon I would take
one I'm not I'm not [__] you I'd
take one
um you know the funniest part about this
whole this whole [__] tweet here
where she says Jack Smith is a lousy
attorney then what the [__] are you
worried about yeah if he's so lousy and
he's lost so many cases and mistrials
you should be like yeah Bring it on
Bring it on then well it's the same
what he's a lousy attorney then you
should be excited if he's such a shitty
attorney I mean I'm excited about
Trump's attorneys because they're
garbage
they keep dying off like flies you know
one person gets scolded they're like
well this is my career I'm done I'm not
getting paid but in the same same uh
kind of style of of them saying or
Marjorie Taylor green saying well he's a
lousy attorney okay well yeah to Tony's
point then what are you afraid of he's
lousy and he has no case
then why are you scared you're only
scared again for the same reason that
you were asking for a pardon but even
yesterday forget the representative's
name but they were having a Committee
hearing and the question was if you guys
are trying to take and abolish or like
you know defund abolish the part of
Education why do you keep requesting
that the government gets control of the
of the Department of Education to then
control these smaller schools about what
they can say what they can't say if you
don't want it at all right why are you
trying to give the Department of
Education more money and resources to
then control these smaller entities you
either want Federal control or you don't
it's a simple it's a simple thing no
Biden can't be a a a a a mastermind just
like he can't be a guy sleeping on a
recliner in the basement you can't have
it both ways right on Monday he can't be
lazy on Tuesday he can't be controlling
everything they want it both ways so
does Steve scalise and let me tell you
something when this indictment comes up
guess what they're gonna say they're
gonna they're gonna present their
Chinese spy whistleblower to the
American public to prove why Biden
should be indicted not Trump
I'm just pointing out
you know I'm just pointing out that it's
interesting that the same week that you
have this whistleblower coming forward
to testify before three different
congressional committees you see once
again this isn't the only time it's
happened over and over again you see
different attacks by the Biden
Administration against President Trump
and there are many things that you've
seen President Biden do again the
documents you know raiding Mar-A-Lago
when you have documents behind locked
doors with secret service and yet when
Joe Biden had documents in his garage
in some cases in public view surely not
in the same scene I got a question is
Elise Jordan looking at Steve scalise's
ass the entire time I I no I I she's
looking at his ass the entire time I
don't know why I don't know if he's got
something if he like he has like toilet
paper hanging out or something I don't
know but she's like his ass
he went through a lot of surgeries when
he got shot remember that nut bothered
yeah one of the surgeries they did is
they stuck some butt implants in and and
I mean
it pops man oh okay he walks down the
Holocaust
he's got that BBL then huh oh my God
he's got that bbo and she's she's like
she's all in on it man I don't know
maybe someone needs to check to me like
sure I'm gonna get that all right at
least stefanik isn't uh isn't isn't uh
celebrating pride month still I don't
know I'm just saying but look look at
that little smile on her face look at
her she's staring at his ass here let me
let me mute this I'm gonna back it up
I'm telling you watch or or yeah here's
an alternative uh-huh possibility yeah
there it is she's looking at that he has
a Bodacious booty yeah it's that [__] is
overflowing from his pants and she's
like oh God I see it it's coming down oh
he needs it next am I next he needs his
diaper changed and they're trying to
change his diaper I'll tell you man let
me let me give you an idea Steve scalise
is not a low energy guy if you've ever
watched him like give a price guy he's
really not a low energy Guy this is
[__] low energy this morning these
people are sick and tired of having to
do this [__] over and [__] over and
and over and defend this idiot they want
him to go the [__] away but he's not
going to go anywhere anytime soon they
know that that's why they're willing to
do this stupid [__] show that they
keep doing where they defend him it's
weird as [__] well they have nothing
left it's the only play they have even
before they they took the the very very
very slim majority in the house they Jim
you know James Gomer was saying hey I've
got this stuff and we're going to hold
Biden accountable and we're going to
make sure that we bring the corrupt
Biden family to Justice we are going to
make sure that they pay for what they've
done and we're going to take over and
they they were campaigning on that way
before they took over way before and
then what ended up happening is once
they did get control they're like oh
[__] now we gotta follow through with
the promises that we made we can't just
then victim blame and say oh well we
didn't have the majority the Democrats
did now they have the majority they had
to play the car that they did and what
did they do they overplayed their hand
at each point they tried to reveal that
they had some new information but what
did we find out James Comer had recycled
stuff that was in the reports they were
reusing content there was nothing new in
there they kept saying they had this
whistleblower this informant well they
go missing another one goes missing
everyone's like how are we supposed to
trust you if you can't keep a [__]
eye on where these people are James
Comer says oh well they're spies so who
knows where they are they're in the Spy
game business like there's a [__]
movie like yeah well they turned out to
be a spine they turned out to be a
champion and then it was like oh well we
can't have it then we got and then it
was 5 million then it was 10 million
then it was 20. that was [__] a
billion dollars whatever it might be now
yeah good no it's it's up to it's up to
gillians it's up to the same thing
our country's dead is right right
they're like oh that's how much money
Joe Biden took and then when they
finally do have the informant oh what
happens the informant is on the [__]
run and he sends a video to the New York
Post and says I have to now send this
video from an undisclosed location
because the the government is coming
after me and then Republicans are like
oh yeah the government is coming after
him I wonder why right I mean we talked
about this last week the reason that
they came after him is because he's a
[__] criminal he was not only a
Chinese spy he's a foreign agent with
Iran too the guy is so corrupt and it's
always the projection with these guys
and they're still bringing them up
they're still bringing him up because
again that's the last thing they have
they were hoping that they wouldn't be
tested they would not be challenged they
would not be proven wrong they would not
be fact checked or debunked or anything
they thought that if they said well they
just put it out there it was gonna be
truth it was going to be golden right
but what did we find out people like to
look on the internet they like to search
around and like to add double check some
of the things that people say and they
claim and now that's all they have they
only have because it whittles down to
this
he's the guy that was supposed to be the
[__] Smoking Gun
and he ended up being a [__] spy well
watch watch Eric swallow hear stuff Jim
Jordan in the trash can over some of
this stuff this is hilarious watch this
it never gets old that chairman Jordan
is complaining about subpoena compliance
we're approaching 500 Days since
chairman Jordan has failed to comply
with a lawfully issued subpoena for the
greatest crime ever committed in America
a crime where more people have been
arrested more people have been
prosecuted this country has asked him to
assist in the investigation and he has
refused to comply yet he is all too
eager to bring to this committee people
who are working hard for the government
working hard for taxpayers to carry out
the mission of Health and Human Services
to carry out the mission of the state
department
he's too good to honor a subpoena but he
has complaints real complaints about
what these hard-working government
officials are doing again it's never
going to get old it's never going to be
taken seriously thankfully these
Witnesses are willing to do something
that chairman Jordan is not willing to
do which is actually show up and answer
questions
I mean you can't argue with the
hypocrisy and the just the absolutely
dumb [__] in the house and it's the
reason why they're not going to get
anything done and they're not going to
do anything before the election they're
not gonna have anything to run on Texas
Paul I mean what what platform other
than their Chinese spy whistleblower are
they going to be able to run on
uh nothing they have nothing except for
trying to trying to attack they're
trying to do the same thing they pulled
with Clinton
trying to do the same thing they try you
know they they tried to do with Carrie
it's it and they can't figure out why
it's working they don't understand that
you and me and you know
Midas the you know Ben micellis is out
there every day pumping into a
microphone what's actually going on we
have completely kneecapped their ability
to do the Swift boating [__] and
they cannot wrap their heads around it
they just cannot you know scalise
talking about gal look being there I
have one of those sexy dreams you know
you ever have one of those dreams that
are like are we about to go zero days
talking about porn because I think that
we're headed there I think we're headed
now my my sexy dream is that they
actually produce galileft
and then that you know and in my dream
you know in your dream it's your dream
it's the way it you know you've got
you've you've got uh Jasmine Crockett uh
Jared Jared Moskowitz uh Dan Goldman uh
Jamie Raskin Eric swalwell are all up on
the same you know days they're just
watching this guy be carried in and then
they all
and just go to town on him man I mean I
just I dream about them you know every
time one of these Republicans stands up
and says oh this whistleblower is gonna
I'm like please produce him please
please please all I want for Christmas
is for you to put gal love
in a hearing please please no [__] right
well I think I think Trump's going to do
that tonight on the on the Fox News Town
Hall whatever he's going to bring his
shovel too
um and he's gonna he's gonna dig this
grave deeper and deeper and deeper
tonight I'm gonna love it tomorrow we're
gonna play I'm sure it's probably gonna
be two hours of me just dumping on that
[__] uh whatever he's gonna say
tonight it's gonna be fantastic so they
expect that tomorrow he won't be able to
help himself I mean it happened before
you know anytime these indictments
happen then he's like a day or two later
he's got a town hall I mean I'm I mean
we're going we're going 3-01 indictments
here it's getting pretty exciting I'm
I'm looking I'm looking forward to the
Fulton County one and potentially others
who knows man there might be other [__]
out there that we have no idea about and
it's common for him but I mean like who
knows we might have four we didn't have
five I mean look dude it's anyone's game
at this point but right now we do know
that Trump is losing he's losing bigly
and he is [__] himself [__] night
and day worrying about this he sent a
press release play I only had to read
three cents an end to know that this guy
is [__] freaking out oh yeah
absolutely that was a full page that was
there that was a there's two pages oh
there's two pages
they're saying half by 11. they're
saying the [__] second page is
crazier than the first page speaking of
uh speaking of someone who's losing I
want to check in here uh with Rhonda
Santas here let's let's see what Ronnie
let's see what kind of excitement he is
to be yet another institution in
American life that gets infected with
the woke mind virus this is changing the
character of the military everybody
changing the culture of our services uh
and it's creating a situation in which
great warriors have been driven away and
recruiting is at an all-time low post
abolition of the draft in the Vietnam
conflict I mean everyone in the room
just sees and throws post the Vietnam
conflict yeah right yeah this is the
lowest point even the recruiting Zone I
believe him but you know you know that
happens every time there's an amazing
economy because you know you know what
it also happens when there's no when
there's no [__] War when there's no
[__] War that's another thing that's
another thing that happens when there's
no Wars to go to you don't typically I'm
just fighting I feel I feel like Ron
DeSantis right like right at the
beginning of that clip like within the
first 10 seconds he goes woke mind virus
he does not know how to Pivot right we
already know that the group that he's
affiliated with the DeSantis war room
which is a copy of the Trump war room
their account quietly deleted the
homophobic disgusting ad that they put
out there Casey DeSantis uh DeSantis
doubles down and she makes her own
homophobic ad
and he just continues to put out this
idea that it's whoa whoa whoa like woke
is a winning strategy selling though
it's not selling no of course not he's
losing veterans watch watch this this is
on Newsmax watch this watch watch what
they do to him and so with Dei is
telling people to do is to elevate our
differences Elevate different
ethnicities gender race you name it uh
and balkanize people and put them into
different groups that's not good for
society but it's definitely you're
listening to Florida Governor Rhonda
Sanchez speaking live right now well
that's some boring [__] let's get on to
another topic uh what's the weather like
in Mar-A-Lago oh I gotta say that we
should just mayonnaise all cultures I
mean yes
all cultures should be mayonnaise yes
tell me what was what is wrong about
well first off elevating okay there's
nothing that is controversial about the
word elevating right elev invading other
cultures elevating those who are diverse
I mean we we know it and the audience
knows that when you have a diverse board
room or diverse team or a diverse
cabinet you have the best decisions and
the best solutions that come out of it
because you have a diverse set of
opinions and experiences Ron DeSantis
wants this the same vanilla Mayo
combination that's I do this you also do
that I think this you also think that
and also I will take my cues from Casey
DeSantis because I don't have thoughts
of my own
what's funny is news even Newsmax is
like get this [__] offline well
this Jesus Christ as boring as [__]
apparently Texas Paul there's a lot of
people leaving his team how many think
you're gonna go work for Trump
oh God I couldn't even give you a number
but uh you know I'll be honest anybody
that has any inside dirt on DeSantis
will be snapped up immediately I mean
this is the stupidest move I have ever
seen I mean nobody believes that his
team is behind him pulling his string
making him say this stupid [__] and and
and to put on full display that you are
dumb enough
to to actually think that people are
going to believe that you firing these
people is is going to make it all better
is is it's just ridiculous I mean he's
just keeps shooting himself in the foot
I'm surprised the guy can even walk I
mean he just keeps shooting himself in
the damn foot at everything he's got
those fancy white boots that's why he's
got them fancy boots
right that's true how much money did he
just spend trying to create the the
illusion that Ron DeSantis is in control
man wasn't it 13 million dollars and at
13 million dollars in the last six weeks
I think they spent like 13 million 13
million I think so I think so I think
they spent 13 million in the last six
weeks and he had moved a bit
in their stupid [__] polls that they
say and you know you know the other
thing is Vivek ramaswamy is actually
closed in on Ron DeSantis which is
crazy to think about oh it's almost like
the polls are rigged I don't know maybe
I'm wrong that guy speaking of Vivek
Rama Swami that idiot wants to take away
[__] Birthright citizenship which is
the very thing that he benefited from is
that why he's running for is that how
he's running for president you mean
that's one of the things that's one of
the things I mean he's he's you know
that's literally his qualification his
Birthright citization right I'm not
gonna actually run for president right
but he wants to take that away yeah
but it's because Trump wants him to say
he wants it to take it away yeah that's
he but Meck is not running for vivec
reveck is running so Trump can say see I
have a challenger and Vivek go you're
the greatest thing ever Mr Trump and I
agree with every single one of his
policy points I would do exactly what he
to do so why would you vote for me just
vote for him
I'm looking forward that's what you're
gonna do if the day comes that he's
actually on the debate stage I'm looking
forward to Vivek ramaswamy like watching
watching Ron DeSantis and Donald Trump
go at each other I'm waiting who's Vivek
Rama swampy that's a good question I
mean you is in the swamp as he as he can
get but I will say this I'm looking
forward to the day when this first
debate happens and we've got Ron
DeSantis versus Trump and we've got Rama
Swami over there cheerleading for Donald
Trump and saying yeah actually I don't I
don't have any critiques on what Trump
did while he was President I mean there
was a question that was asked
um
when he was on The Breakfast Club okay
and they they asked I think Charlemagne
tha God said uh all right so you have
any critiques for for Ron DeSantis and
Donald Trump and he goes well and he
just he just skirted around it would not
give a direct criticism to either of
them the fact that you're on if you're
running for president and you don't call
out the mistakes or the failures and how
you can actually correct and be better
than the previous one of the of that
party then why are you running if not to
be a little spoiler candidate or a
puppet for Trump
that's that's all that it really is it's
I that's all it is speaking of trump
here's oh my God what is this garbage oh
my God this is part of the statement I'm
not gonna read all this [__] Jesus
Christ they say the second page is
better than the first but I'm not even
gonna attempt it Jesus I I gotta have
some bandwidth to operate this afternoon
um this is how it starts this is the
official statement from and I'm not
[__] you this is real Trump make
America great again 2024 statement by
President Donald J Trump 45th president
of the United States he says wow that's
the intro to it uh it's weird
um but okay on Sunday night while I was
with my family what is this [__] when I
was with my family stuff then only
Melania doesn't even spend time with him
anymore he don't give a [__] if you're
with your family or not they don't care
when they're going to indict you whether
you're with your family or not you
[__] idiot having just arrived from
the turning points Nazi uh event in
Florida does it say Nazi I might have
added that
um where I won the straw poll against
all other Republican candidates with
85.7 sounds rigged to me with all polls
showing me leading in the Republican
primary it sounds rigged to me by very
substantial numbers almost everyone
predicting that I will be the Republican
nominee including me Amber predicting it
I I love how people brag about these
straw polls like they have any any
ground to stand on I mean well they're
as weak as a straw themselves the idea
that you're gonna go in it's it's so
heavily biased it is but that's the
whole intention is this well no
propaganda convince them that he's ahead
that's the whole intention with the
struggles when you remember that the the
Turning Point USA event that happened in
Florida I think it was Charlie Kirk that
said there were thousands of people yeah
and somebody somebody maybe it was like
700 people and the way that they did it
is they had it they had a software that
scanned through and identified heads
that were in the audience so they
enhanced the image and they scan through
and they were like ah there's 700 and
something they're they're not nine
thousand they're not thousands of people
they said nine thousand I forget what
Charlie Kirk said exactly he said
several thousands
but I do know I mean there might have
been several thousand within the
Insanity of that Arena but he goes on to
say he goes on to say I will be the
Republican nominee for prison and as I
hate all the people that that paid for
tickets that were stuck outside that
wanted to beat the [__] out of Charlie
Kirk
that may be where he's getting the
thousands that's probably where he's
getting it all the protesters that
showed up to protest the Nazis that were
there in support of Charlie Kirk and his
turning points oh no his own audience
these weren't protesters his own
audience turned on him and it was just
beautiful they were so pissed off a lot
of these people traveled across the
country you know he's got these people
that follow him around you know what I
mean right well because he does the
University thing he does the University
thing yeah they they bought tickets for
this and couldn't they Fire Marshals
wouldn't let anybody in because it was
such a small venue that's hilarious it
was such a small venue they were outside
screaming all kinds of [__] at him I
mean it was it was really great are you
serious I didn't see that [__] but here
he goes I am leading Democrat Joe Biden
in the polls by a lot okay
horrifying news he says in Campbell
Letters for our country was given to me
by my attorney derange Jack Smith the
prosecutor with Joe Biden's doj who else
would it be he's the president you
[__] idiot send a letter again it was
Sunday night oh my God Sunday night
stating that I am a Target capital
letters I don't know why of the January
6th grand jury investigation and giving
me a very short four days ah boo [__]
who to report to the grand jury which
almost always means an arrest and
indictment it definitely means arrest
and indictment because you're a criminal
and Jack Smith knows that they've got
the evidence they they're going to
present it to the Grand Jury they're
going to ask for charges and he sent you
a letter on Sunday night because that
motherfucker's working 24 7 against you
and it should terrify you that you got
the letter on a Sunday night
like how is that like like oh my God
they're so inept like dude he's working
seven days a week man yeah
he's seven days a week on your ass like
he's not taking any time off that should
terrify the [__] out of you that that
Jack Smith is sending you letters on
Sunday evening like a love letter
and this was such a beautiful uh
rope-a-dope by Jack Smith I'm telling
you this guy I you know watching him
operate man I'm telling you it is just
just amazing
sends him this target letter on a Sunday
because he knows Big Mouth can't keep
his mouth shut so this is going to be
the news cycle for the entire freaking
week you know if if I were if I were
Donald Trump you know I mean if I was in
his position I would have shut the hell
up about this I wouldn't have told a
freaking Soul until next Friday at 5 00
pm
and it would have died in the weekend it
would have died over the weekend I bet
they tried to convince him of that I bet
they that's why they didn't do it
yesterday's because it took them all day
yesterday to try to convince him not to
[__] do this and he finally did it
this morning and the reason why is
because he wants to go to this town hall
on Fox News and he wants to talk about
this that's why he did this this morning
so he can talk about this tonight on Fox
News that's what it is that's what it is
and I'm like don't do it don't do it
don't do it he's like okay I'll do it
but we what we know I mean like the
behavior is there the pattern is there
history repeats itself but we only have
to look at the last two indictments the
guy has literally told I mean you could
look at the the search that the FBI did
these are things that we only know
because Trump put them out on true
social or he released the statement
nobody would have known until after the
fact or if somebody had been buying like
taken a photo while it was happening all
of these things we were given heads up
real time notice by Trump and Trump go
oh well God forbid they dude it's dude
nobody would have known nobody would
have cared nobody would have said oh
[__]
okay Mason Mason here on YouTube says in
Trump's voice I'm gonna come I'm gonna
come uh it's it honestly again it is all
coming back to the fact that Donald
Trump is the one who gives us this
information right and his and his Clown
Posse the the the Maga the the citizens
of magedonia whatever the [__] they call
themselves now these people are are
waiting they they cannot go a day
without getting information from Trump
and then reverse it and say oh well he's
the victim they're coming after him well
they gave him heads up he didn't have to
tell anyone he could have he could have
he could have been [__] silent and
and that would have been fine well he
has the right to remind he has the right
to remain silent he's just under the
[__] ability okay he cannot shut his
[__] mouth
you know what I love though man and Gabe
you know this is and Tony you you you
know there are real Republican
strategists that are trying to manage
the Fallout from all of this Trump BS
and just the just the you know their
eyes what was that movie where the clip
where uh um you know he gets the roller
coaster scene and the guy's like ah
when these all of these strategists are
like
he came out and said this on Sunday
freaking night
he's gonna go on Fox News and he's going
to talk about this he's going to give
them so many freaking talking points
he's gonna make this the the the message
going into this entire freaking election
is going to be this message and you know
their eyes were just all you could see
were the whites in the bottom of their
eyes oh yeah they do they do not I mean
Donald we know Donald Trump the only
thing that Donald Trump has said he was
going to do I mean
it was going to be the fact of uh
of his platform the the promise that he
said he's going to drain the swamp in
six months which you know credit to Ron
DeSantis if you were in there for four
years why didn't you do it then right
we only know that that is that is the
platform that Donald Trump has it's it's
drain the swamp six months drain the
swamp I'm gonna drain the swamp that's
all he has if he doesn't have that and
he and and he's challenged on that on
that basic premise of you had four years
of that why didn't you do it
the only other thing he can did where do
you think he found Carey Lake right of
course but but but what I mean to say is
is he he does not have the ability to
defend himself when he says oh well I I
didn't do it then he he has to distract
and the only thing he can distract with
is playing the victim and saying oh look
at them they're coming after me they're
trying to attack me and he's going to
try and navigate that narrative to make
sure that the whole town hall or
whatever this [__] with foxes is
going to be full of that right well
Chris asked why did he wait till Tuesday
to announce it it's because the town
halls tonight he wants to control the
news cycle because he can't control not
getting indicted like he can't control
that that's gonna happen with the
January 6 case so what he wants to do is
he wants to be able to get out in front
of the indictment because the indictment
is going to be scathing and if Jack
Smith writes this indictment like he
wrote the documents indictment it is
going to give detailed it is going to
give material evidence in the indictment
showing why he's guilty of what he's get
what the charges that they've they're
turning him on my guess that's my guess
and the reason why is because we've seen
that in the um the indictment in the
documents case with the Espionage Act
but Chris my guess is the reason why
they waited till this morning to do this
and he posted this as an official
statement as a two-page [__] lunatic
um
just a [__] rant on a statement and
again I'd love to read the second page
but I'm not going to do it here on there
is because they're setting up the
narrative to to get their sheep to to
project lies out into the universe when
the truth actually falls on the
indictment that's my guess
um speaking of trump saying and not
keeping saying [__] and keeping his
mouth shut listen he hates America did
you know that I knew that did you know
that let's let's listen
but you know that's a keep America great
and I was going to use that but then
with each of them you could never use it
because they've let America go down the
tubes America is not great
America's not great Texas fall that's
what he says America is not good can you
can you two tell me Texas Paul or Tony
one of you can you can you tell me about
this recession
did a recession happen it's a big one oh
man it's a horrible one is it not good
anymore stock market stock market the
stock market crash unemployment is way
up whoa gig prices do you see what
happened Hank prices oh my God you can't
you won't believe when I tell you what
happened
I loved you know the CEO of Bank America
came out uh with the earnings reports I
mean everything's been fantastic this
week we've got a like Bank of America is
like the economy is I mean you couldn't
ask for a better economy it is growing
they've managed to slow the rate of
growth so that inflation has fallen it
is just
chef's kiss the most beautiful freaking
economy
that we've ever seen I mean they're
literally these Bank executives are you
know pleasuring themselves looking at
these economic numbers coming in at you
know the strong job growth the the fact
that every time we turn around GDP keeps
creeping up and creeping up and creeping
up but it's doing it in such a way that
it's a long game you know like we had
the the long consistent growth in during
the Obama Administration we're looking
at it at that 2.0
and these Republicans are just losing
their damn Minds I mean you've got
Ukraine you've got you know everything
that he's getting through as far as the
infrastructure is concerned you here in
the states Biden I I believe Biden could
actually go on vacation
and not partake in this election and win
the election and just come back in
refreshed and you know looking good A
little tan on you know I mean just I
mean who knows who does not have to
participate maybe he'll go uh visit one
of Trump's golf courses you know it
could be yeah the front or maybe the
back nine who knows I don't know maybe
he'll go look for some documents do you
think he'll order some pants do you
think uh Joe Biden will order some pants
over the uh over there if he doesn't I I
just know that he's got to have pants
and he's definitely got to have socks on
because Republicans get very upset about
them no socks thing now Gabe I told you
yesterday that there's audio there's a
recording LBJ ordering pants it's the
[__] most hilarious thing
um in the historical Archive of
presidents that that I think probably
exist Texas Paul has not heard this
either so
um I'm gonna I'm gonna show you guys
this this is [__] hilarious I hope
the sound is Okay let's listen
hello
hello Mr tiger yeah
uh Joe or uh is your father the one that
makes the clothes yes sir we're all
together you all made me some real
lightweight
slacks uh uh he just made up on his own
sent to me three or four months ago it's
a kind of a light brown and a light
green rather soft green and soft Brown
now I need about six pairs for summer
wear
so I need about six pairs of wear around
in the evening when I come in from work
and I can send you a pair I want them
half a inch larger in the waist than
they were before except on two or three
inches of stuff left back in there so I
can take them up about very 10 to 15
pounds a month okay
so leave me at least two and a half per
inch in the background let them out or
take them up and put it make these a
half inch bigger in the waist make the
pockets at least an inch longer money up
my money and my knife everything Fall
Out Boy just
hello hello
now another thing that crunch down or
your nuts hang is always a little too
tight so when you make them up give me a
inch that I can let out there
uh because they cut me it's just like
riding a wire fence these are almost
he's the best that I've had anywhere in
the United States but uh when I get a
little late they cut me under there so
leave me uh you never do have much
margin there let's see if you can't
leave me about it an age from where the
zipper yeah
[Music]
now be sure you got the best zippers in
them these are good that I have
and if you get those coming I would sure
be grateful
White House
I just sure will appreciate this I need
it more than anything and uh now you
give this boy the address because I'm
running for a funeral and give him a
dress just how to address these trousers
so we'll send them to you don't you you
get the measurements out of them and add
a half an inch to sit back give us an
inch to the pockets and about a inch
underneath so we can let them out
here he is I doubt it okay go ahead
please
stride in the crotch a little stride in
the garage down where your nuts hang all
the way back to the bunghole you know I
would probably I'd probably safely
assume that's never a problem with
Donald Trump he doesn't have the issue
of big balls you know because and with
big balls you know that a presidents
they don't
you know they get [__] done that is real
that's not AI That's real that's
hilarious yeah when you told me about it
I was like oh my god I've never heard
that before and the fact that there's
this animation to it even oh it's great
well and the the funny part is is when
he belches too like yeah just it's a
normal conversation you can see he's
getting it working it up and then he
just lets her out did you know the lgbj
would do interviews with with reporters
while he was on the [__] like he
would do me he would hold meetings while
he was taking a [__] that's probably why
he fluctuated 10 or 15 pounds a [__]
month it's called multitasking right
depending on how many shits he's taken
good Lord he used to do that he used to
actually do that to stat his vice
president I mean it is actually a real
story that Hubert Humphrey who was quite
the gentleman I mean he was he was a
very polished individual uh LBJ called
him into the [__] while he was taking
a dump
and they just sat there laying out some
political agendas right there I mean
just just while they said
Hubert you need to get them folks in
line
I mean right I mean Jesus man I mean
that's incredible no time to waste
there's no time to waste when you're
when you're the leader of the Free World
yeah you know I think there was like a
war happening while he was President you
know I can only imagine him on the
[__] and being like all right we got
to deploy 500 000 troops and he's like
yeah
whoo that was a big step brought up
another one bit big stuff brought up
another one that was actually true he
would have the gaggle of reporters with
him you remember there was the big deal
where you'd hold his dogs up
by the ears yeah and everybody had a fit
about that because it was cruel and this
that and the other another thing that
went on you know and everybody heard
about he's scared the [__] out of people
with his car that would that you know
the had one of them old 50s cars that
could you know was a boat and a car you
know what I mean he'd pretend he lost
his brakes and slam into the lake you
know but the other thing that he did
that the press used to cover up was he'd
have the Press Gaggle with him and he'd
be talking to him he would be walking
and talking and he'd walk up to a tree
unzip whip out his Johnson and just
start taking a piss while he's talking
to him in the press conference Big Stuff
brought that that was literally true he
would do that and they would stop taking
pictures
you know and then they you know he would
just sit there and tell them you know
them damn Republicans over there I'm
just oh got my shoe and and then I mean
he was that way he was just really that
freaking real man I mean he had no couth
whatsoever not a single lick of it I'm
I'm gonna I'll tweet this um this link
on Twitter and I'll put it on thread
Steve if you guys want to go watch it if
you want to if you want to re-watch that
little ditty uh there there's there's
several different versions of it on
YouTube that one happens to have the
cartoon which makes it better it kind of
helps tell the story visually uh when
he's talking about you know having extra
room where his nuts hang and because he
doesn't want to get cut like a wire
fence and you know make sure they're
running all the way back to his bungle
yeah I was gonna say he said bunghole
that's yeah that's probably you know
that and the burp were so great he's
like yeah right next to my buddy you
know another good story about LBJ about
the showers apparently he had a shower
jet installed two watches
that's LBJ for you and he he apparently
liked to uh use sort of a bidet type
thing to uh he was having more time man
hey man how many Japanese were doing he
was like man they got these bidets over
there right I hear it's great I hear the
days are great the bidets are great I
mean some of them I went to I went to
Japan a few years ago and some of them
will sing you a song a little tune while
you're in there if you know she'll make
noises I guess it is no [__] because
yeah the point but like some people you
know some people have uh a little
anxious if they're in a public space
right so then right well and if you're
getting water shut up on your ass you
might be a little yeah you know but the
idea I mean like I remember entering a
public bathroom and then it was like
like it had this little jingle and then
it like
got everything ready and then I sat down
and then boom boom boom I was ready to
go I mean it's it makes sense I wish I
had a bidet I know they they sell
extensions they could put on your toilet
yeah it's like a toys
that didn't used to be a thing like 15
years ago you know why they did that
to save water
they did it to save water because in the
Japanese culture you don't want anybody
to hear you fart man you don't
so they would sit there on the toilet
the whole time and just flush and flush
and flush and flush and flush and flush
and flush so that nobody could hear what
was actually going on in that stall so
they did it to save water they they
would they blast it's kind of loud music
too wasn't it I mean it wasn't like
subtle it was it was oh yeah I mean the
Acoustics in the bathroom the the one
spot the little cafe went into the
Acoustics really brought it out to the
whole room and now and if the first time
I walked in because I'd used it the day
before but the first time I walked in
and like little jingle happened I was
like
is my ass singing to me now that I've
treated it to a bidet I don't know
what's going on here God damn I've never
used a bidet to be quite honest I
recommend it it's nice you know the
toilet paper the toilet paper Lobby here
in this country is pretty heavy I mean
some some days uh I've got friends who
have them and they have heated seats
yeah they got all sorts of settings that
you can do I don't need any other reason
to sit there for any longer my legs fall
asleep already I'm sitting there you
know taking a [__] looking at PornHub I
mean uh Twitter and so I meant to say
Well they're you know they're more or
less one in the same wow it happens
sometimes there is porn on Twitter and
I'm not gonna say hey you know what we
got a birthday in the chat before we go
I want to tell happy birthday to Wayne
happy birthday happy birthday to you
happy birthday Wayne thanks for coming
here to the Tony Michaels podcast we had
a big audience today I think it's
because uh Trump is losing his mind we
got Texas Paul here it's a Tuesday it's
Taco Tuesday so thanks for joining us
here if you have not already make sure
you hit that subscribe button you also
hit the like button as we wind down the
show it helps us get into the algorithms
over there on YouTube also visit
realtexaspall.com that's real
texaspaul.com his links are in the
description down below if I'm youtubing
right they're in the they're in the in
the bio down below those links
realtexaspaul.com go follow him on
threads and also follow him here on
YouTube you're not going to want to miss
his show tomorrow morning Wednesday it's
right before hours on Wednesday and he
has a Sunday show Texas Paul do you have
anything special for us tomorrow
uh you know man it's just I I'd be
honest with you it's going to be the
Trump show it is as more information
comes out uh about about the indictments
and as he makes an absolute jackass of
himself tonight uh we're gonna have to
talk about it we just do because he's
he's actually the
going to be the nominee of a major
political party yes he is unfortunately
isn't it sad but it's true it's sad but
it's true Gabe sanchez-diamony what was
that I've got a I've got a what was that
I should be rolling out tonight that's
all about it's the Marjorie Taylor green
uh fellatio blow collaboration music
video
uh and then yeah I've got a few more on
the list but that'll be the next one
immediately coming out so make if you're
not part of the patreon make sure to
sign up get Early Access
and chat with all the other lovely
people that are in the audience here
patreon.com I am Gabe Sanchez that's
patreon.com I am Gabe Sanchez of course
that Link's down in the description
below and while you're on patreon you
come over and visit my page as well and
you can watch this show tomorrow as you
do every single weekday the same time
noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific on
Facebook go over on Facebook if you
still got that meta account at the Tony
Michaels and then follow us on Twitch
it's free to follow us on Twitch and if
you got your Amazon account your Amazon
Prime account tied to your Twitch
account don't forget to re-subscribe
we've had several do it today or
re-subscribe for four months three
months four months so don't forget to
resubscribe with your Amazon Prime
account tied to your Twitch account go
to twitch.tv slash meet Tony Michaels if
you need directions on how to do that
just go to thetonyminkles.com that's the
Tony michaels.com and support the link
down on how to tie your Amazon Prime
account to your Twitch account and give
us that one free subscription Texas Paul
is ready with this fact bat for tomorrow
for a show and I'm sure he's gonna post
some videos I'm telling you what just
having something to put your hands on
while you're talking and thinking I
don't know what I mean where do you why
do you think my hands are down here all
the time anyways man it's on my fact
back I just can't show you I just can't
show you my fact bat and said something
I you know
I'm sure LBJ talked about his backpack
yeah he did he did it's down where your
nuts hang all the way back to your
bunghole you know what I mean you know
Tuesdays I cannot believe that is a real
[__] piece of audio but it is and it
is the funniest piece of audio probably
in a presidential archive uh that
probably exists and it's it's great it's
hilarious I think it was released like I
don't know about 10 years ago when they
were starting to release some lbj's
records in this library in this this
recording of him ordering pants uh came
out so it's fantastic that's what we do
here at the Tony Michaels podcast we
covered the presidents that are traitors
and the presidents who need tailors we
cover it all here on the Tony Michaels
podcast so don't miss a single episode
Monday through Friday noon Eastern 11
Central 9 Pacific on YouTube Twitter
twitch until tomorrow same time same
place Surf's Up [__]
you've been listening to the Tony
Michaels podcast in your face commentary
of current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] them [__] em
[Music]
Murphy's mealborn headass Beacon
hello hello uh Mr tiger
uh Joe uh is your father the one that
makes the clothes yes sir we're all
together you all made me some real
lightweight
slacks uh he just made up on his own San
Antonio three or four months ago it's a
kind of a light brown and a light green
rather soft green and soft Brown now I
need about six pairs for summer wear
so I need about six pairs uh we're
around in the evening when I come in
from work
and I can send you a pair I want them
half inch larger in the waist than they
were before except I want two or three
inches of stuff left back in there so I
can take them up I very 10 to 15 pounds
a month
so uh leave me at least two and a half
per inch in the background let them out
or take them up and put it make these a
half inch bigger in the waist make the
pockets at least an inch longer
hello
hello now another thing that crunch down
or your nuts hang is always a little too
tight so when you make them up give me a
hint that I can let out there uh because
they cut me they just like riding a wire
fence these are almost these the best
that I've had anywhere in the United
States but uh when I gain a little late
they cut me under there so leave me uh
you never do have much margin there
let's see if you can't leave me about it
an edge from the where the zipper
ends uh around under my back from my
bunghole
so I can let it out there if I need to
now be sure you got the best zippers in
them these are good that I have
and if you get those coming I would sure
be grateful uh
I just sure will appreciate this I need
it more than anything and uh now you
give this boy the address because I'm
running for a funeral and give him a
dress just how to address these trousers
so we'll send them to you don't you you
get the measurements out of them and add
a half an inch to the back give us an
inch to the pockets and about a inch
underneath so we can let them out
yeah that's right
okay here he is
okay go ahead please